home to many of the gods in Greek
mythology Mount Olympus was created
after the war between the Olympians and
the Titans a war that finally ended
after ten years and saw Zeus and his
fellow Olympians victorious Olympus is
often described as containing a fabulous
palaces made of marble and gold
mythicist
the highest of all of its peaks was
referred to as the pantheon this is
where the gods would gather and many
fierce discussions and arguments took
place within the pantheon there are many
gods and goddesses who were believed to
have lived on Mount Olympus it is the
twelve Olympians were most commonly
depicted as making Mount Olympus their
home with Poseidon and Hades chosen to
live separately
[Music]
the ancient Greek poem Iliad describes
Olympus has been an ancient Acropolis
essentially a fortified hilltop somewhat
of a palace complex located just below
the peaks of Mount Olympus located on
the lowest level of the mountain or the
nine Muses
who would often entertain the gods of
Olympus the golden gates that led to
Olympus were not guarded by any creature
or monster
they were guarded by the three goddesses
of the seasons the main feature to
Olympus was indeed Lucis palace much
larger than the palaces of the other
gods and goddesses despite the size
Lucis palace still had a very simple
layout with a large central hall private
bed chambers and some storage rooms the
main hall had floors made from gold and
often served as a council chamber and a
feast hall for the other Olympian gods
as it provided them with an expansive
view of the world allowing them to
observe mankind from the heights of
Olympus the tables and furniture of the
Great Hall were created by the divine
smyth Hephaestus and they were animated
so they could present themselves when
needed and packed themselves away when
the feasts were over
outside the palaces of Olympus was a
lush land teeming of exotic fruits and
herds of cattle there was a large
courtyard where all the gods would
gather including those of Earth and even
the sea deities sometimes even nymphs
were invited Olympus was more than a
lush land filled with exotic fruit and
vegetation the gods had an abundance of
anything that they would have ever
needed to the gods Olympus was just the
home that they deserved nothing more and
nothing less to everyone else Olympus
was a paradise that they only wish they
could have visited Mount Olympus is
indeed an actual Mountain located in
Greece the highest in the country there
are those who believe that the gods
never lived on the mountain
Olympus knows more as a metaphor as it
reflects the social hierarchy in Greek
mythology Mount Olympus been the highest
point would naturally make sense as home
of the gods as they are elevated above
all mortals creatures and demigods able
to look down at those they were
considered to be above and rule over
[Music]